it's clear that Wes is in possession of
a brilliant mind and prodigious talent
but more importantly as an
artist he has had a profound influence
on the perception of his people when we
think of Native Americans in film his
are some of the most distinctive
performances that we all remember his
work is part of a remarkable and
necessary Cannon but when we think of
masterful cannons it's important to
remember that they reflect only those
who've had the opportunity to
participate too few opportunities in
film on both sides of the camera have
gone to Native or indigenous artists
we're a room full of people who can
change that it is imperative that we
do